[Music]
the earliest-known pregnancy test dates
back to 1350 BC in ancient Egypt
according to the Egyptians all you have
to do is urinate on wheat and barley
seeds and wait if either sprouts
congratulations you're pregnant
and if wheat sprout stir it's a girl but
if barley it's a boy in 1963 a small
study reproduced this test and found
that it predicted pregnancy with a
respectable 70 percent accuracy though
it couldn't reliably tell the sex of the
baby scientists hypothesized that the
test worked because pregnant woman's
urine contains more estrogen which can
promote seed growth now it's easy to
take this ancient method for granted
because modern pregnancy tests give
highly accurate results within minutes
so how do they work over-the-counter
pregnancy tests are all designed to
detect one thing a hormone called HCG
HCG is produced in the earliest stages
of pregnancy and starts a game of
telephone that tells the body not to
shed the inner lining of the uterus that
month as the pregnancy progresses HCG
supports the formation of the placenta
which transfers nutrients from mother to
fetus the test starts when urine is
applied to the exposed end of the strip
as the fluid travels up the absorbent
fibers it will cross three separate
zones each with an important task when
the wave hits the first zone the
reaction zone y-shaped proteins called
antibodies will grab on to any HCG
attached to these antibodies is a handy
enzyme with the ability to turn on dye
molecules which will be crucial later
down the road then the urine picks up
all the ab1 enzymes and carries them to
the test zone which is where the results
show up secured to this zone are more
y-shaped antibodies that will also stick
to HCG on one of its five binding sites
scientists called this type of test a
sandwich a say if HCG is present yet
sandwiched between the a b1 enzyme and a
b2 and sticks to the test zone allowing
the attached die activating enzyme to do
its job and create a visible pattern if
there's no HCG the wave of urine and
enzymes just passes on by finally
there's one last stop to make the
control zone as in any good experiment
this step confirms that the test is
working properly whether the a b1
enzymes never saw HCG or they're extras
because zone 1 is over stocked with them
all the unbound a b1 enzymes picked up
in zone 1 should end up here and
activate more dye so if no pattern
appears that indicates that the test was
faulty these tests are pretty reliable
but they're not fail proof for instance
false negatives can occur if
concentrations of HCG aren't high enough
for detection after implantation HCG
levels double every 2 to 3 days so it
may just be too early to tell and
beverages can dilute the urine sample
which is why doctors recommend taking
the test first thing in the morning on
the other hand false positives can come
from other sources of HCG like IVF
injections ectopic pregnancies or
certain cancers such as uterine cancer
or testicular cancer making it possible
for one of these tests to tell a man
he's pregnant the best way for a woman
to find out for sure is at the doctor's
office the doctors are also looking for
HCG but with tests that are more
sensitive and quantitative which means
they can determine the exact level of
HCG in your blood a few minutes can feel
like forever when you're waiting on the
results of a pregnancy test but in that
brief time you're witnessing the power
of the scientific method that one little
stick lets you ask a question perform a
controlled experiment and then analyze
the results to check your original
hypothesis and the best part is you
won't even have to wait until the next
harvest
you
[Music]